we're gonna draft the best players in
the best division in football the nfc
west i've got the trivia question for
chris sims if he gets it right he gets
the first pick since realignment in 2002
chris only two divisions have sent every
one of its teams to a super bowl
name them and i'll give you one of them
one of them is the nfc west name the
other team that has sent all four teams
to the super bowl
since 2002 okay that's i'm gonna go with
the um the nfc south
damn it
i shouldn't have given you the nfc west
i would have got the nfc west don't
worry i would have yeah
baby
i was trying to i was trying to do the
jedi mind trick where you would go with
an afc division that's what i was trying
to do
right uh nope you got it all right you
get the first yep
hey too smart right here man 24 on the
wonderlic you're not gonna trick me okay
all right i'm going with aaron donald as
my first pick
all right uh aaron donald is a tough
call for the top pick all right but
aaron donald might be one of the
greatest defensive players i've ever
seen all right and i know i'm not
picking russell wilson here who's
completely awesome but aaron donald as
it sits right now is a first ballot hall
of famer has a chance to go down as the
greatest interior defensive lineman
we've ever seen you know so again i
really love russell wilson i can't
believe i didn't pick a quarterback to
start this but i'm gonna go with aaron
dotto because i think he's been the most
dominant force on the defensive side of
football for about the last four years
in a row
yeah and it's amazing when you think
back to the 2014 draft the teams that
needed defensive tackles that just
passed on the lions the most glaring and
dominic and sue either was leaving or
was entering the last year of his
contract i think he was entering the
master of his contract i think so
fairly at the time who was entering the
last year of his contract they had needs
looming and they did not pounce on aaron
donald and left him on the board for the
then st louis rams to take all right
you're going to leave me russell wilson
i'm going to take russell wilson just
like the lions left aaron donald on the
board you're leaving russell wilson on
the board one of the best quarterbacks
in the nfl top three in your estimation
a first ballot hall of famer whenever
he's done he's said multiple times he
wants to play until he's 45 there's no
reason to think he won't be able to play
at least until he's 40. he's now 31-32
he's still as good as he's always been
that team is built around him and
there's a reason why the seahawks have
had a winning record every year of
russell wilson's career it's called
russell wilson so
the best player in the division and i
won't say by far because of aaron donald
but still i think he's the best player
in the division one of the best
quarterbacks in football and will
continue to be for years to come
yeah i listen i i have no problem with
that no argument i really just didn't
want to pick the quarterback i feel like
the quarterback always gets first
billing it was very close and i went
with aaron donald but man i love me some
russell wilson and i don't think it's
even you can't argue it i mean he's one
of the three best quarterbacks in
football i don't care whose list it is
he's just phenomenal and i don't know if
there's too many people out there who
have a clue or watch football that would
uh argue otherwise whoo man what am i
going to go here right here all right
i'm going with nick bosa i can't believe
i'm picking a rookie but i am i'm going
to pick nick bosa because
i think nick bosa you know again
a lot like we've talked about with aaron
donald and russell wilson and everything
like that he's in the conversation for
one of the best pass rushers in football
already i mean mike how many people did
we talk to during the season or even
uh at the super bowl when they talked
about playing the 49ers how it all
started with stopping nick bosa stopping
97. man is he unbelievable can you see
what he does on film every week he's he
is he's a top flight pass rusher every
bit worthy of that second pick of the
draft last year he was the best player
on that defense last year for the 49ers
special he really made them a super bowl
defense and yes you know forget the
sacks he's he's a f to play up type guy
too he does a lot more than what the
stats will tell you
so if i follow what you're saying here
about nick bosa and i agree with most of
it are you suggesting that the arizona
cardinals got it wrong when they took
kyler murray over nick bosa
no i'm just saying right now as of year
one i think nick bosa's a little ahead
of kyler murray okay i love kyla murray
um but no you take the quarterback when
he's that special and you need him so i
i understand that pick all the way for
the arizona cardinals no but i just
think yeah nick bosa gear one the effect
he had on football
the 49ers defense yes i'm going to say
he's a little bit better right now than
kyler murray
and this just shows you how great the
nfc west currently is defensive rookie
of the year chris's second round pick
nick bosa offensive rookie of the year
for the entire league just like bosa was
the defensive rookie of the year for the
entire league kyler murray the cardinals
quarterback that's my pick you're
leaving the quarterbacks i'm taking the
quarterbacks you're gonna leave two of
the best quarterbacks in the nfl on the
board for me i'll take russell wilson
i'll take kyler murray we had a draft
not that long ago of the best rivalries
at the quarterback position in the nfl
it's going to be murray and wilson head
to head twice a year every year
indefinitely i love it i especially love
it because they're both about my size at
least from a height standpoint so uh
tyler murray was spectacular last year
we didn't notice it because the team
wasn't very good i remember the first
time we watched him play in the
preseason chris the ball explodes off of
his hand it explodes into the hands of
the receiver he doesn't run recklessly
he doesn't run carelessly he doesn't run
gratuitously he looks to throw first
he'll use his legs when he has to
special talent the arrow is pointing up
for the arizona cardinals and look you
know we we've joked in the past and i
don't know how much we're really joking
about it with with now three wild card
births per conference
would it shock anyone to see all four
teams from the nfc west make it this
year and the one team that i think is is
the longest shot would be the rams who
were the super bowl team not that long
ago
no i mean you're right it's it's
phenomenal i mean yeah and then rams of
course still got players on that
football team that garner a lot of
attention and are super talented in a
lot of ways so i don't think they're
just going to fall off earth this year
and not be relevant at all either so
yeah between the quarterback play you
know the the coaches in the conference
you got some freaky defensive football
players
man i mean it's it's it's hard to argue
you're right with the talent and it's
very real could be an
uh a conference that has three teams or
a division that has three teams in the
playoffs here going forward maybe four
in the right year which would be amazing
man i don't know what to do here
i mean these are two of my favorite
players jaylen ramsey and deandre
hopkins are on the board and i love both
of them oh man i'm going to go with
d-hop though i am gonna go with deandre
hopkins here it hurts me because i like
jalen ramsey he's like my one of my man
he's one of my man crushes but deandre
hopkins i think just the way he played
last year the way he's played the last
few years he's in the conversation with
michael thomas for the best receiver in
football i think there's some things he
does better than michael thomas really
and that's probably win on the outside a
little bit more of a deep threat on the
outside of an offense that way might not
be as good in the slot as michael thomas
is he's really special there but deandre
hopkins i mean hey there's a reason
arizona made that trade there's a reason
they're flirting with making him the
highest paid receiver in the history of
football or at least going to be in that
conversation there's really nothing the
guy can't do you know he's got
phenomenal hands arguably the best hands
in the sport he can go over the middle
he can beat you deep he can make plays
after the catch i'll go with deandre
hopkins i'm sorry jalen ramsey man i
like you a lot
you know we have the de'andre hopkins
jaylen ramsey battles in the afc south
now they're both in the nfc west and
they'll see each other twice per year
ramsey fell off last year and was it
injury was it circumstance does he need
a full off season to get properly
ensconced with the rams although this is
not the offseason to really get
comfortable anywhere if you're still
getting your feet wet in a new city and
i don't think he's going to be with the
rams over the long haul i think they
should have gotten him son to a
long-term contract on the way in i just
think that they're going to decide at
the end of the day they're not going to
chase those two first-round picks and
fourth-round pick they gave up to get
him with a huge contract that they think
maybe he doesn't deserve i'm not taking
jalen ramsey you left him on the board
i'm not taking him i'm taking the guy
that you didn't even mention and and and
i thought you would at least mention the
guy one of our favorites george kittle
the 49ers tight end who can do it all he
can he can catch passes and yes he is
one of the best blocking tight ends in
all of football he is a football player
he is relentless he is hard-nosed and
here's the thing about george kittle
if they have to play games this year
without fans we talked last week about
that which guys will will be up for it
who will be the brian dawkins that will
get his team in the right frame of mind
i guarantee yeah right that it will be
every week george kittle getting the
49ers in the right frame of mind when
they run out into that stadium where
there's absolutely no one there so yeah
i think
all the more reason to make george
kittle part of this and it's it just
shows you this isn't an affront to
george kittle or jaylen ramsey it shows
you how many great players there are in
the nfc west that george kittle was the
last guy taken in a two-team three-round
draft
no it does i mean it's superstar i'm not
even gonna lie i'm not gonna lie i got
like eight names down i'm an idiot i
didn't even write george kittle down
okay because i was having some technical
difficulties leading up into this draft
we didn't talk about chandler jones
who's been one of the best pass rushers
in football the last few years you know
to speak to what you're saying even more
so yes there is a ton of talented
football players in this division that's
why it's been one of the best in the nfc
and uh man i can't believe i forgot
george kittle but mike your point about
the no fans in this crowd
could be a very real thing you know
the teams that have maybe some players
with more some more personality and more
juice on a daily basis as compared to
maybe the teams who have taken more
conservative players by nature who were
not rah-rah guys
yeah i think those teams that it took
you know some of the personalities and
renegade types
might have a little more juice in those
environments where there's no fans on
the field and everything like that and
be able to bring their team's intensity
level up a little bit it's a very
interesting you know psychoanalysis
conversation it really is
apologies also to bobby wagner and
richard sherman who weren't even
mentioned until just now patrick
peterson was mentioned earlier in the
show i have a feeling he wasn't on
chris's list
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports